Falafel Inc. started out as a single restaurant in 2017.
Now, owner Ahmad Ashkar has over 20 locations worldwide.
He credits the restaurant's success to special family recipes.
Falafel Inc. is no ordinary fast food restaurant.
Ashkar's eateries also use his family's recipes to make food for refugees.
So, with every meal, anyone who purchases at Falafel Inc., we help feed the poor...
...and feed the hungry.
And since launching, we fed over 250,000 refugees,...
...people who otherwise wouldn't have had anything to eat.
Ashkar also employs refugees and immigrants including Imed,...
...who works as a cashier at the Washington DC location.
Imed says he's proud to work at Falafel Inc....
...and intends to help others like himself.